[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little singing you think that's me
every little sing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'd be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything anyone who
contributes two dollars or more over at
our patreon page can attend this special
live stream if you can't make the live
stream itself the live session the live
podcast don't worry you'll still have
access to the private video and the
private audio podcast efforts recorded
we hope to do this at least once a
quarter maybe more frequently for our
patreon supporters and please note that
none of the money from our patreon
campaign goes to our personal bank
accounts rather what we're going to do
is use these funds to build our own new
podcast studio and a film studio we're
just going to allow us to do a bunch of
really cool things like take live
callers on the air improve overall audio
quality and bring guests on the show
we're also going to hire a full-time
filmmaker to create a video version of
this podcast and we also want to produce
a bunch of other meaningful video
creations like webseries TV shows
interviews documentaries video essays
and more and because we refuse to
clutter our podcasts with advertisements
patreon really is the best way for us to
fund these creative endeavors together
so let me ask you this
are you willing to help if so please
become a patron today head on over to
patreon comm slash the minimalists or
you can go to our website it's just the
minimalists comm and click on the donate
button at the top we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well and
please know that your support is greatly
appreciated together we will create
something meaningful
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means because there's a meaningful
life with less
my name is Joshua field filburn and I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimal end we are live in Grand Rapids
Michigan hello Grand Rapids
what a great video I was walking around
most of the day today and actually will
get through that in a little bit because
we have an added value segment we could
talk about some really cool local things
but usually if we take this time to take
callers but that would be really weird
so instead we have a microphone right
here and we're going to start with three
sort of long-winded answers you can ask
the regular question will give you a
rather circuitous monitoring answer but
uh well we hope to answer your question
so someone has to break the ice and get
to the mic first and what will happen is
everyone will cascade down to it after
that and then it will be too late
because we'll do three and then we'll do
a lightning round where we'll do 3 plus
questions and and Ryan I've you're
scoring that is right we're turning into
a rap battle except Ryan and I don't rap
so we just try to give tippy answers to
your questions so if you want to come to
the mic give us your name and what your
question is and we'll be happy to do our
best to answer it I guess do an Andrew
I've been paring down a lot of stuff in
my life and I'm left with things like
old cameras or old iPhones stuff's I
think is valuable but it's really
worthless to me
everyone just chuck it in the trash so
what do you suggest for trying to figure
out a good home for it let me ask you
this are you you want to sell it I
really don't want to go through the
hassle really like I have all these
iPhones they like seven iPhones you know
I'm just like every model I have like a
little collage you have like a museum
revive phone I do
so I'd like to give it to like you know
maybe something like you know somebody
get some use out of it cuz it doesn't
work like as a phone but maybe somebody
could like use it to browse the Internet
or or something to that extent
sure so we just start a museum a museum
of iPhone yes okay so that's one one
piece of advice but so here's the thing
we're with with our electronics one of
the reasons that we hold on there are a
few reasons we hold on to something like
that one is this idea of some cost and
it seems to me like you've gotten past
that where you're like you realize that
that $800 iPhone 2 is no longer an $800
artifact and that's good most of us
however we hold on to this thing because
we're life but I paid $800 for this and
you're like yeah but it's not really
worth that anymore it's worth what
someone's willing to pay for it right
now you're like I don't even want to go
through the hassle so it's literally
worth $0 to you and in fact it's worth
less than zero because it's there's all
these additional costs that go on top of
the price tag so if we buy something
that's usually what we think of as the
cost of the thing right we think of like
well I paid $5.00 for this widget but
then we don't think about all the
additional costs as well like the cost
of storing the thing replacing the
things batteries changing the oil and
the thing putting gas in the thing
cleaning the thing replacing the thing
all the time the thing takes what up and
eats eats away from us and then of
course losing the thing repairing the
thing and there are all these additional
costs the real cost of owning a thing go
way beyond the price tag and then of
course there's there's one other cost
that you have here and it's the the cost
of the space this occupies in your mind
right now where you're like it's a
burden and so we have all these
additional costs and you're experiencing
one of those costs right now and there
are some practical things you can do
most most shelters whether it is a woman
shelter or a homeless shelter there are
a lot of places who will repurpose these
devices they'll do one of several things
to them some of them will take them and
sell them for you so there
is some market somewhere for your iPhone
three and and the question is how much
is that worth
it may be worth only 20 bucks but to
them it's an additional $20 contribution
toward their call so someone else will
get value from the thing if you part
with it there are some other things you
can do with it as well there are some
different websites and on Craigslist
obviously you can just you can just try
to get rid of the thing I know that even
that is a bit of a hassle at some point
and then other things that aren't that
you may not even be able to get rid of
you continue you can usually recycle
them there are places that have
recycling bins I know where we are there
are a couple places there's a donation
warehouse there's also like the local
Target does they have like a bin where
you can put old cellphones and old
batteries as well that you no longer
using so I think that's the point where
I'm going here is you can find a way to
repurpose the thing and you actually end
up saving in the long run not saving
money but saving all of these additional
calls the the space the mental clutter
the internal clutter the anxiety in a
very low level it's all I grew up your
panic coming like oh my god I can't live
my life if I don't buy keep holding on
those iPhone 3 it but that's also the
reason we have 300,000 items in our
houses right is because there's this one
thing I can't figure out how to get rid
of times 200,000 and that's what happens
it becomes this this little cycle of
incremental clutter - good good essay
title cycle with incremental clutter but
that's really what what our lives are
filled with and that's why it's
important to keep asking that question
of does this add value to my life you're
way past that you've already figured out
that it doesn't not now the question is
whose life will it add value to yeah I
totally feel you on the you don't want
to like nickel and dime every little
thing I remember after the packing party
I started well after the packing party I
invited Josh over to like help me sort
stuff and I just remember it was kind of
quickly where he had like this big 50
gallon like garbage bag and he was just
like sweeping stuff into it and I'm like
going through things one by one and I'm
like we do it man and he's like what
what do you
these coffee mugs I'm like what well
I've got like you know 40 of them like
maybe if it's like 38 of them break then
I have like an extra to to like hang out
so I was very much caught in the
adjustment case but also like the nickel
and diming meaning my TV for example I
had a I don't know it was like 60-inch
[Music]
780 be like you know one of the older
model TVs that I had paid I was like
1,200 bucks for and I remember putting
it on Craigslist at first for like 700
bucks
no no takers like 500 bucks
no take very much yeah and I did that
for a few weeks and finally I was just
like you know what it's like I just
hiking it out you know 200 bucks out of
this thing I'll be I'll be really
grateful for it and I put it on there
for like 225 and you know some kid came
and talked me down at 200 bucks but he
was like so happy that he got this huge
TV for 200 bucks like Evan his
girlfriend like they just moved in
together like he was telling me this
whole story like that we just moved in
like we don't watch both of our parents
are talking to us because we've been
together and and he's like it's so hard
to like you know get stuff and I'm so
good I'm in but it felt really good to
be able to like contribute to that kid's
life I mean even though I'm so charging
200 bucks I mean here it was pretty
happy about it and then I remember like
I had this surround sound system I paid
like five or 600 bucks for and I was
selling it on Craigslist I think for you
know 200 bucks or something and long
story short this guy talked me down to
60 bucks and when he came to my house he
was like I was like so excited to get
get rid of this and he was like all
right man um you know let me go ahead
and see it and like you know we turned
it on the speaker's worked everything
was great it's a great great I'll take
it I'm like awesome and he's like I just
want the receiver like he didn't want to
take the other speakers with it he's
like I'll give you 60 bucks I'm like no
dude you bought all this
and you had enough taken everything you
do is lay alright it's like I'll find a
use for it or you know go donated or
whatever but I guess my point is is like
yeah there's a certain point where it is
a sunk cost and you've got to ask
yourself like is it if it's going to
take me you know ten hours to sell this
100 dollar thing I mean it's ten bucks
an hour like it can I do something for
ten hours and make more than 100 bucks
and if the answer is yes then I would
just encourage you to to donate it I
mean you've already said that it means
well not that it means nothing to you
but the value to you is nothing but to
someone else that could mean a lot I had
like an iPhone for that
I don't know how many models ago that
was but it was something I gave away and
like it by that time there were a few
models that have come on after that and
I just finally had retired my iPhone 4
and who I gave it to they were like so
estatic about oh my god I've never had
an iPhone before so even though like you
may not see that direct result you may
not find that person you know who's
connected with you directly that's going
to get that that kind of benefit or joy
out of it but I promise you man like if
you give it to one of the organizations
or that that Josh talked about or you
know give to a goodwill or something it
will find a good home and you will be
adding value to someone else's life I
mean you may not find any value in it
but there probably is someone out there
you definitely will find value in it but
at the end of the day it is sunk costs
you already look at look at it like it
is sunk cost I've taken them across the
country just box them up and take them
from New York to Chicago Michigan
they've traveled more than most people
in this country that's all so man you
know what's interesting about that is I
would so it's going to take you 15
minutes to get rid of them and when you
think about it give yourself three times
as much of that put that time on the
calendar so put 45 minutes on your
calendar at some point this week not
only does that give you a deadline but
it gives you time that's allocated
specifically for that now I think
whenever like with Ryan when he did his
packing party and we spent a whole day I
mean
really busting our asses to pack up
everything his huge house it made sense
to do it that day otherwise it was never
gotten done it was just scheduled and
and and that was that so you can do it
this weekend and you'll feel
incrementally free or as a result thank
you thanks brother thanks sir how did
you know Miss Sophie hey Sophie um first
of all thank you for coming to Grand
Rapids I was at your show in Boston over
Easter weekend and it was amazing so I
found the next closest one to me Oh came
here that is awesome so my question is
how do I begin to let go of any stress
that I might feel when I see my friends
and family around me not aligning their
short-term actions with their long-term
goals yeah so so let me just rephrase
your question Leviticus I think it's an
important question and the way I'm going
to rephrase your question is align their
actions with their short-term actions
with their long-term values because I
don't really I'm not prescribing this to
anyone else but I don't really have
goals anymore and I know that's a weird
thing to hear in our culture right in
our culture you seem like a crazy person
or a lazy person Ryan and I are in the
middle of a 40 City tour I assure you
were not lazy but we're also I don't
think we're that crazy but but the
reason I prefer to I shoe goals is I'd
rather have a direction to go in then
have a goal that I'm working toward and
there's a reason for that so let's say
that for example we're in Grand Rapids
right now and if my goal is to to make
it to San Francisco like that's my goal
I want to travel to San Francisco but
all of a sudden I end up in Seattle or
Los Angeles instead because there's some
awesome detour and I ended up in a
better place well if you have a goal if
your goal is being in San Francisco
technically you failed right you but if
you achieved a better outcome then you
probably didn't fail at all and so what
I prefer to do is say instead of I'm
going to go to San Francisco I said I'm
going to head west and I'm going to have
an ideal sort of horizon in mind but I
try to be flexible enough that I can end
up anywhere else and so that flexibility
is first off is key so my question to
you is are they headed in the same
direction as you and if not then it's a
different conversation all together
sometimes they're just and in this in
the same direction but they get there
via different paths so if you want to go
to San Francisco from here there's a
bunch of different roads you could take
right and the question is are they just
taking different roads to get to the
same place as you that place to continue
the metaphor are our values right and so
the reason Ryan and I get along so well
is because we have similar values but we
do have different beliefs the beliefs
are the roads that get us to those
values so for example we voted for
different people in the last election
how could you be best friends with
someone who didn't vote for the same
exact person as you or you know what we
we have different personalities he's an
extrovert I'm an introvert he's very in
the moment I plan things out six months
an event and I'm more detailed oriented
he's big-picture guy and so but we still
have the same or similar at least values
you want to get really clear on what
your values are first I think that's the
most important step you can go back and
listen to a podcast or reported about
values there's episode numbers 69 I
believe and it's about someone laughs at
that
[Music]
yes it's episode 69 I get the reference
okay anyway I probably shouldn't have
paid that any mind real mature man oh I
couldn't help it anyway once you get
clear on what your values are and then
you can start talking to them in a way
that smell like hey what are your values
because then you're going to get the
deer and headlight saying the Ryan was
talking about during his talk well
you're just going to be like they're
going to look at you like you're what do
you mean one of my values and you want
to get clear on yours and you want to
help other people uncover theirs without
saying here are your values you can
start to identify what theirs are and if
you're heading in different directions
sometimes you go in different directions
from someone and that's okay and there's
nothing wrong with that
I've never dragged anyone why I have it
now I mean but in the past like that
felt like that was the right thing to do
like well if you don't believe what I
believe then I better hold on to you and
drag you kicking and screaming so you
know that I'm right well how does that
work out for anyone I mean even now
we're not out here telling people that
we're not proselytizing I don't want to
convert you to minimalism by the way I
don't think that's possible like I just
want to share a recipe that's worked
really well for me and I've seen that
similar recipe worked really well for
thousands of other people and in doing
so me heading in that direction a lot of
people are willing to follow because
they see the value in that as well and
so even people who thought I was crazy
when I first when I walked away from the
corporate world so I walked away and
everyone is actually what competitor are
you going to and can you take me with
you and I'm like no no no I'm just going
to go right like I wanted to write
fiction full-time that was my whole
thing I was going to work at a local
coffee shop and and then this whole
thing happened and it was a beautiful
accident but um I I found that those
people like I said well it's just it's
crazy if you can't just like go pursue
what your dreams are
and and I said well maybe you can but
I've chosen to write and you can't only
because you're saying that you can't you
have a limiting belief there and so did
I for a long time and I'm going to start
walking in this direction and they're
like yeah whatever this guy's crazy
he'll be back or whatever and the truth
is six seven years later they're calling
me asking for advice and that's because
I continue to go in a direction where I
knew my actions were aligned with the
person that I wanted to be that's my
short answer oh I got it I have one
question before I answer your question
did you say when you hang out with
people and their actions don't align
with their values or don't align with
your values what their values are so
okay so I've got like some friends and
family who and I'm probably guilty of
this at some point where I'm like man I
really should do X and my actions are
completely different than was like I
would love to become vegan again for
example I write don't applaud me yet
because I just had to like a delicious
lobster roll earlier today
yeah but I mean my point is is like I
would one day like to go back to those
principles I have not made it a priority
yet and I'll tell you the best thing
that anyone can do for me Joshu I
probably see more than anyone is is to
support me and to really go out of their
way to accept Who I am and not try and
you know force me into whatever that may
be I mean at the end of the day if
someone what if someone says oh well you
know I shouldn't I shouldn't put things
on my credit card anymore and then you
seem going out to lunch and they put
things on my credit card like to say to
them hey wait a minute you said you
weren't going to put any things on your
credit card anymore like that is the
worst approach to take because hey
you're embarrassing them be you're
making them feel guilty and that's
always going to cause a little bit of
resentment I mean that's just the road
to not go down for sure so I guess
unless that's what they're asking for
well yeah well I don't know why drew
much true and if he was like hey Jojo
McGriff above vegan tomorrow you would
say something like if you ever see me
eat a piece of meat slap it out of my
hand
right so you what they want though right
so that so maybe maybe the answer is to
not ask us what to do but ask that
person what to do
and you know the next time you hear that
person say oh man are you know this is
really what I want to be then you can
ask them like hey what can I do to help
you to get there and that's what a good
friend does and that's what a loving
person does and I'm sure the people
you're talking about you know you love
them you want them to be happy and in
that case you will support them and at
the end of the day just ask them how to
support them but certainly calling them
out and yeah trying to trying to be
there you know authoritative figure is
not going to it's not going to get you
lasting results if any results at all
yeah and one last thing
surround yourself with some mentors
people who
I'm not saying that are like actual
mentors where you're like I want you to
be my mentor that's usually not how
mister ship works but but we often think
it is like we're gonna reach out to this
person and tell them on what I want
because if someone comes to me and says
can you be my mentor I'm just thinking
like how much work do I have to do but I
also know that like I'm a mentor to a
lot of people in different capacities
right and so surround yourself with
people whom you aspire to be like people
who are older than you and people who
are younger than you as well who have
who have different perspectives
different personalities different
beliefs you know I encourage you to find
those different paths so you can so you
can continue to figure out and make sure
that you personally are on on the right
path thank you
thanks for being here Thanks how did hi
I'm Amy and I may have made the Dutch
mafia comment and I apologize because as
I'm sitting in line I probably ignored
all the things you said for the last two
people that were in line because I was
focused on my thing so um I apologize
also if I get emotional a little bit um
my dad died two weeks ago well okay but
I am a grandchild of depression-era
grandparents and they saved everything
and my parents when they died when the
grandparents I'd saved their things and
now that my parents are not my people my
dad passed away I have three generations
of things that I am going through and I
come from a hoarding background a little
bit and so I already hole I already have
myself my stuff so my question my
question
is I don't know if I had a question is
just how how how do I handle hold it my
a my a my dad passed away my rock my
best friend I'm handling all of this my
mom has dementia and I'm handling all of
that and on top of that I have their
stuff yeah I have eight boxes of
pictures in my living room right now
because I had to go through them and
they're sitting in my living room how do
I handle that well let me let me ask you
a question first and it's important one
what the [ __ ] is the Dutch mafia you got
to tell me I have no clue we save money
and say things and wear wooden shoes and
they're super cheap okay okay so yeah
Hollanders yeah we like I asked that
question specifically for a reason it
was to change your state a little bit
right and to make you smile a little bit
because I could tell you it's I
understand how overwhelming and health
saddening that experience is you know I
went through it myself both of my
parents have passed at this point and
and I can tell you the most important
thing for you to do right now is a not
be isolated and be find ways to change
your state short-term and that can mean
change your physiology I just stood up
out of my chair that's one of the ways
you can change your physiology right
away right to manage a bunch of
employees and they they come in because
I manage I manage a bunch of retail
stores 150 retail stores which is really
ironic for a minimalist
I wouldn't do that again in fact that's
why I left because it didn't align with
my values and but when I was managing it
was a bunch of like hormonal 21 22 year
olds and so they're constantly either
manic or depressed and at the same time
yeah yeah well it was been an eight hour
shift for sure and so like they would my
boyfriend just broke up with me and I'm
like look here's what you got to do and
once you go in the bathroom right now
lock the door
look in the mirror with the biggest
smile you've ever made put that smile on
your face and I want you to jump up and
down for ten seconds in the mirror no
one's going to see you but if you do
that you come out then I'll keep talking
to you about this issue and I know it
sounds crazy at first until you try it
and it is it's not crazy but it's stupid
you're gonna my boss what the hell am i
doing right like I just got a big smile
and I've dealt that up in death but all
of a sudden you feel that like it's
impossible for you in that moment
not long-term but in that moment for you
to feel that same level of sadness or
depression or anger or frustration or
overwhelm because we have the physics
physiology to actually change that and
so so when I started teaching that to
two different employees I saw that their
results were better after they wouldn't
did that had nothing to do with with
like you know I mean I was happy is it
like maybe it helped them through a you
know a moment where they were feeling
sad about a breakup but their results in
real life you know for them it was like
they were doing better odds during their
work shift but I found that the same for
me when I change first my physical stay
and then I change what language I'm
using or write instead of I'm
overwhelmed by stuff maybe you start
saying things like I miss my father but
I realized that he's not in these things
and if you start changing the language
around these things you'll find that
it's easier to let go but be it
comes necessary to let go because these
things aren't doing anything for you
except giving you those negative
emotions and we both know your father
wouldn't want you to experience that at
all man um so it's been only like two
weeks so this is this is hard really
hard and I don't want to there's nothing
I could say to make it easy in fact
[Music]
regardless I guess if where someone sits
with something that you've had to go
through or whether they're sitting with
a hoard of things in their house I mean
there isn't really an easy answer I mean
that's why in the beginning I'm like hey
I'm talking about a deliberate life it's
not a perfect life or even an easy life
but a simple one and unfortunately I
think we we look at simple and we find
it synonymous with easy and it's not it
is a very difficult thing so I guess
like the first piece of advice I would
say to you is we wait until wait until
some time has passed and you're ready to
like go through everything but you're
going to have to come up with a plan on
how to deal with all this stuff whether
it is with other family members or
whether it's with friends you certainly
need to have some kind of support some
help to go through all of this but I
think that's where it starts is coming
up with a plan to like the pictures for
example I know that like I used to have
boxes and boxes of pictures and when I
went through and I'm like okay I'm going
to scan I'm going to go ahead and scan
all these pictures yeah like if it as
long as you call it a spent two and a
half hours at Kinkos for like a fraction
yeah it was like $40 I'm just like yeah
yeah in this way - yeah so let's like a
million dollars and in such terms I got
it
well you know even though Josh was like
hey let's have a scanning party which
putting the party at the end of anything
I mean it sounds fun in the end you got
me hooked but it still Frank right I was
going to say I'll bring the beer but no
I mean it still was a lot of work but
what I was saying is when I was going
through a lot of those pictures um there
were a lot of them I didn't feel like I
needed to hold on to and I'm not going
to put an amount on there because I
think that's going to be different for
everyone but yes you spent two and a
half hours at Kinkos you've got a bunch
of scanned pictures you have more things
to go through you're going to have to
spend another weekend two and a half
hours at Kinkos another million dollar
million Dutch dollars to spend there and
more you buy a cheap scanner I recommend
and you money it's probably the way to
yes it was you can go to our website
show you exactly like those same scanner
that Ryan if you get good as the
minimalists comm slash scanning ryan is
scanning for you yeah I'm not
advertising anything
it's our website no it's free yeah you
don't have to get a scanner you can keep
spending 40 bucks every time you go to
Kinko's
we don't care nobody you know at the end
of the day um it's I wish I could be
like you know what grab our three books
on your way out and watch her
documentary and you'll know exactly what
to do um that's not really how it works
I mean it's going to take time and it is
going to take a plan and it's going to
take a lot of action on your on your
part and the people around you to to
help implement that plan I guess like
the one thing I want to throw out there
is like give yourself you know however
long you need I mean there will be a
point where like you're never going to
want to do it so if I sit here and say
wait until you feel ready like you're
never going to feel ready but you're
going to get to a point where it's going
to be it's going to go from like being
upset to you have to take action it's
going to start
being more and more stressful uh you
know when you know you you know when you
get to that point like don't put it off
or set a date a month from now or two
months around whatever you think would
work I mean that would be even better to
set something up ahead but yes it's
going to it's going to take a lot of
work it's going to take a plan and it's
going to take time there's no doubt
about it but I guess the one thing I
will definitely encourage you to keep
doing is asking these questions and
continuing to to take these small steps
towards filtering through all this stuff
the worst thing you can do is get a
storage unit and just put it all in
there and ignore it that's that is the
last thing yeah don't do that that's
that's not gonna make you feel any
better thank you thank you thank you
alright before we before we move on
anyone who's listening to us at home if
you have a comment or tip for anyone who
has asked a question so far today or
anyone else who does you can leave us a
voicemail at four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send us a
voice memo from your phone at podcast
awesome minimalists comm and we will air
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan you know time is you
know what time it is what it is time for
our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round
yeah nice we are on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook ask the
minimalists and they're in the lightning
round this is where we do our best to
answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response and the problem with that is we
usually have a week to prepare our
answers to your questions and now we
have sort of seven days we have like
seven seconds so we'll do our best but
we'll probably will probably mandra on a
bit and eventually come up with a pity
answer for you howdy what's your name hi
my name is Katie okay and I'm going to
break the rules I actually have two
questions hopefully you can sum them up
in one pithy answer when the first clear
related emotions are very challenging
challenge one answer with two questions
all right the first question is before
you put your corporate jobs did you plan
for your retirement when some day you
don't want to do any work anymore and my
second question is how often do you do
laundry oh man um I haven't hit the
answer but I'm we need to go first
alright so the first question had to do
with retirement how do we mix retirement
and laundry into one response for you oh
man I was all right I'll give you my
pity answer this is kind of lame but
this is like just kind of all right so
once a week I do laundry and once a
month I contribute to my retirement
account oh good I'm not even [ __ ]
finished we're going to ruin your own
answer both are non-negotiable ah yeah
there's a little bit of applause there I
heard someone I bet it was an one whoo
all right folks but before I left the
corporate world yeah absolutely I
contributed just to my 401k out of out
of every paycheck and you know in fact
if you want to see this is not my pity
answer but if you want to see my net
worth down to my pin down to the pennies
give or take some market fluctuations
you can't go to the minimal calm slash
retirement I think that's it um yeah and
you can see are you exactly what well
how I allocate my retirement you also
learned that words certainly not
millionaires but not that there's
anything wrong with being a millionaire
for the millionaires in the room wait I
thought congratulations to you I thought
once I thought once we got on Netflix we
were millionaires unless you're hiding
some money from me this is going to be a
whole different documentary 20 years
from now
and so and also in the corporate world I
I own 70 Brooks Brothers dress shirts so
I never did laundry then but God your
enter was so solid you can concede I
will concede this one yes but put up I
don't know how that makes me feel they
plotted ladder to you're conceding I
think you kind of won that but I would
say my answer is actually the same as
Ryan I still plan for I don't you call
retirement now I feel retired now and
it's awesome by playing for the future
right whether that's home ownership
someday or emergency fund which is
important so there's some some hippy
truism about sale to plan and plan to
fail but i won't i won't i won't deploy
that one since i've already conceded
thank you very much for your question
thanks a lot hi hello nudists is related
to the netflix thing that's coming out
in 20 years but i'm curious about like
strategies you have maybe just even with
each other you get more successful you
mark my money things are looking good
and how do you like control yourself and
not you know like oh [ __ ] easy take this
vacation buy this thing do that thing
that you weren't about you know that's
about the whole minimalist lifestyle you
know curious about that like how do you
so what do you do once you're a
millionaire josh yeah yeah so my I'll
give my short answer first and then I'll
try to expand on it it's just three
words contribution is key and I think
it's a support because back in back when
I made several hundreds that made
$200,000 a year in the corporate world
which sounds awesome but I I made good
money but spent even better money
and that equation does not work at all
and so I had massive amounts of debt so
I'm debt free now which is which is
really nice thank you
and and now whenever we get a chance to
have more resources whether it's time or
attention or money we find ways to
invest in people so we've gone out of
our way to do some some pretty cool
stuff whether it's bring people onto our
team like we do this tour now we have to
do events for free because we could show
up at a coffee shop and 20 or 30 people
would be there and that was also my oh
my God why would 20 people come to see
us and and now it's like well now we
have to like have a theater and we have
to have security and a staff and we have
podcast Sean here is recording that
ladies and gentlemen podcast Sean
we love you Sean he is the man behind
the minimalism he's our tour manager or
podcast producer and all-around
outstanding guy we also have Jessica
Williams somewhere around here oh she's
right here in the second row hi now and
[Applause]
Jessica does all of our social media she
also runs a nice little podcast of her
own called the the mind Palace you can
check it out her and Melissa Kane
they're sort of like the the younger
doesn't like the the djinn why I gather
they're called Millennials now the
Millennial female version of the
minimalist podcast oh they started their
pockets way before we we started ours so
you can check that out and so we bring
her on the road she helps out with
social media and she straightens Ryan's
hair said you would not talk about that
in front of hundreds of people oh I
think so to talk about
oh yeah anyway she does a lot of great
stuff for us while we're on the road but
we have an entire team of people now but
beyond that we find ways to contribute
to two different communities and I find
that's important so last year we built a
elementary school for 66 kids and Laos
we funded a high school for a year in
Kenya when the thank you
and he's got a bunch of clothes out
there so so we the pulp nightclub
shooting we found a way to do a charity
event done there and in help the 52
living survivors of the terrible
shooting we try to help them as well
thank you and right now did you know
well did you know that of all the people
who have ever lived on earth half of
them have died from malaria sixty
percent of people who have never lived
died have died from malaria and so this
month we're doing something interesting
actually looking for people to help for
every review we get on our podcast which
helps the message to get out to more
people review on iTunes that we get Ryan
and I are donating pin bucks to the
against malaria foundation takes about
thirty five hundred dollars to buy a
lifetime of insecticide-treated Nets to
save one life so about two to five bucks
per net but over a course of a life it
takes thirty five hundred dollars and so
thirty five hundred dollars literally
saves on someone's life so if we get
every there's more than 350 people here
tonight if everyone we're here here
tonight left the review we find a way to
save at least one life and so I like to
do things like that but also encourage
other people to contribute because Ryan
and I can only give so much and so find
other ways to get people involved
whether it's locally in their community
with food kit with soup kitchens or food
banks or Habitat for Humanity or any of
these other places where you can
contribute to your community in a
meaningful way I think that's important
and so contribution is key
[Music]
and you would have thought I would have
thought of something by now um you know
I just I really love the contribution
aspect that Josh and I have been able to
do especially in 2015 like we was I have
a friend who has a non-profit coffee
shop
in packs song Laos like it's the middle
of nowhere for a long time some purposes
like it's one main paved road and as
much a dirt road to shoot off of it it's
just like village after village after
village and now our coffee farmers and
yeah long story short like he opened up
this coffee restaurant a cafe where all
the proceeds go towards building wells
and toilets and like whatever like these
villages need and when he talked about
how he was trying to fill the school
like it was so cool to be like oh dude
like we can help you do that like how
much does it cost to build a school in
Laos it was like fifteen thousand bucks
which is I mean between the you know the
folks that we have visiting our website
and Josh and I it was it was it didn't
take long to raise 15,000 bucks and
going over there and like looking at the
school that they had which was like a
two-room Shack two rooms and there's a
wall dividing it this high so like you
had four people listening it's like the
four feet yeah yes three and a half feet
but whatever but no it's like it was
like it was like a size of like a
quarter of this stage not very big at
all and as the teachers had to talk over
each other when they were giving lessons
because like it wasn't like a full wall
and when arranged they canceled school
because it was dirt floors and like it
would be I mean it was just like um man
I mean just like really you know kind of
grounded me a little bit like well like
this is what kids learn in and it's mm
and
tene the school we built it was a
four-room cement like very nice roof
they were like super excited about the
toilets like in this Shack there were no
there was no outhouse even and in this
new school like they had you know boys
and girls outhouse and they were like
thank you so much for these toilets and
I'm like wow I mean this feels really
good I mean I would love to do more of
that stuff I remember when I was they do
like this whole village gets together
and they do this whole like party
ceremony for you like just basically to
say hey thanks for you know coming out
here and doing this stuff and making
this possible and I remember well first
off like there's a translator right so
everything I say I have to wait a few
seconds and then they translate it and
of course I'm like trying to like crack
some jokes and none of them are landing
I mean they were funny jokes these
people just had notes now I'm kidding
it's hard to translate and you know uh
my jokes into other people's languages I
wanted that you know public speaking 101
they're like don't try to crack jokes on
someone's translating for you but
there's a point that where I was like
you know thank you so much for doing
this ceremony and the whole time like
they were from you know I got from the
translators the whole time like oh thank
you for the American money and the
Americans coming out here and giving us
their money and making this possible
and when I when I was telling them I'm
like you know thanks for all this
recognition I'm like but at the end of
the day like it's the community that
made this happen the money like that was
the easy part like you guys coming
together and building the school
building the toilets getting together
and like make all of this happen like
that is what we lack in the states and
that every single person got like I saw
everyone oh yeah
no community there so I mean that's why
Josh can I do this really is we really
want to contribute ultimately I think we
really want to bring communities
together and I guess I had to give a
short answer I would say well all that
aligns with my values and beliefs right
so I guess what I would say is every day
I try to be the best version of myself
five years from now that's all I got
thank you I think I tied it up there I
mean we have time for one more I want to
apologize anyone else is in line but I
know what we have to move on a video to
kick yourself but we have we have a
tiebreaker sir what is your name Jason
what's up guys brother so no pressure
right yeah all right so a quick back
story last summer my wife and I sold our
house and nearly everything inside it to
pursue a minimalistic lifestyle so
during that process we had to convince
our friends and family that we weren't
batshit crazy
so since then my question is emotionally
how do you navigate just in case when
purging sentimental gifts that you've
collected over the years from those
people and how do you communicate to
them that you no longer need that [ __ ]
you really want us to wrap this up with
a bow like what is the tweet that I can
show them that will live will inoculate
me from their criticism so this is like
stuff they bought you you're saying or
is just stuff in general so it's like so
we sell the house in all of the shift
from art van and Williams and Sonoma all
the [ __ ] on our wedding registry right
right so like yeah in three years we
sold $25,000 worth of [ __ ] Wow
congratulations though awesome man
that's great you know but you keep the
random dumb thing that your mom gave you
ten years ago because if she finds out
you sold it in garage sale she kill you
so how how do you like and she knows
this this process you're going through
so how do you communicate to her that's
like mom I'm never going to use this I'm
never going to set it out guests don't
care that it's there so how do you get
them comfortable with you getting rid of
it because you really don't want it and
then how do you get them to stop buying
you more of it every Christmas but
that's kind two questions
I'm a vegan I'm thinking about I got
married when I was way too young to get
married
and we got three bread makers at that
and I don't eat bread dude I thought you
wanted to start a bakery and and so
three different bread makers all this
actually the same bread maker but there
was just three of them on the table and
to me that was sort of like the perfect
metaphor for consumerism like an
obligatory gift-giving in particular
right and so it's really two sides of
the equation what you're saying is how
do I get rid of the stuff and
communicate that but then how do I
prevent this from happening in the
future
how do they go hand in hand
and the future thing is start setting
the expectation now don't tell people
what you don't want I don't want any
more bread bakers
hey Ryan Canada me - what do you want
for Christmas like I said I don't want a
bread maker all right well I'll get you
something else that you don't want then
it's dead tell them what you do one and
that could be experiences it can be
tickets it could be give kids no no
that's that's part of it we sold
everything because we made the decision
to not have kids okay
got a perspective you a couple weeks ago
congratulations so so sorry sorry buddy
right TMI right so for us for us
traveling and those life experiences are
going to be our kids yeah Alea so I mean
I think of affected me is the truest
form of minimal you quickly jettison the
condoms saving money already there you
go that's my pithy answer you're not
everybody so so I think I think it's
about so so I had something to do with
expectations here so before you let go
set expectations with yourself and
others would be my short answer my my
rant on my short rant on that would just
be that man the people in your life they
want you to be happy they care about you
they want to be supportive if they do
care about you right and you need to
find a way to communicate how you need
their support because right now they
don't understand and it's going to be
different for each person by the way and
for some people it's as easy as a talk I
know with Ryan if you came to me and
said I got you know the breadmaker
I'm like Ryan stop it what are you doing
and and he would do the same thing to me
because we have that type of
relationship other people in my life I'd
be like all that is such a nice thought
and and I first of all I'd never let it
get to that point the first place
everyone in my life knows not to buy me
a bread maker at this point but but if
they ever did for some reason that some
delusion I've also done a good enough
expectation setting job at this point
that that if they come to me and know I
I'm not going to find value in something
they're not going to feel offended at
least long-term by being letting go and
and so I said I would just say yeah just
let go before you let go set proper
expectations but thank you oh man I was
visiting my grandmother I think it was
like Jay it was beginning of this year
January February and when I was leaving
she like came up to me with this gift
bag I'm just like oh [ __ ] like alright
grandma's going to give me a gift okay
and I was I was like I'm like I'm going
to deal with this I'm just going to like
I'm just going to be honest without
being a dick and if she's like hearing I
you this gift before you leave but just
well you know thinking of me and I'm
like thank so much she's my German
grandmother's so like first generation
so to call her OMA Mike thanks OMA and I
pull this like paperweight globe like
literally it's a paperweight globe
oh the bag and I just kind of look at it
and I'm like surely it was literally a
paperweight globe but like like you
could shake it and it would do stuff and
it would also put weight on your papers
like we use that pejoratively right like
how that thing is just a paperweight now
the actual purpose of this thing was a
paperweight
yeah perfect metaphor yeah it had like
some beautiful little saying in it like
you are your dreams I don't know
sometimes it was it was nice fun so I'm
like looking at this and she and she was
like oh you know and she's like I know
you don't like a lot of things in your
life she's like but yeah here's a bit of
like a lot of things in your life but
here's the thing you have your own
business that you're running and I am
sure that you're surrounded by papers um
I don't even know where to begin with my
grandparents on explaining to them how
they could digitize everything I mean
not even know where that conversation
starts with her but I'm like I'm like oh
wow this is a beautiful gift and like I
can tell that you really you really
thought about me when you gave me this
it's gorgeous but I'm not going to have
any use for this you know I would really
love to find someone else who could use
this and she was like that's okay she
was like I just I just wanted to get you
something and if you could find someone
else to use it like that wouldn't that
would be great and I'm really good about
that interaction with her she was happy
to give it to me
I definitely showed appreciation for it
but at the end of the day I was
completely honest whether I'm just like
you know I'm not I'm not going to like
take this book oh nice and then go home
and just get rid of it and she would
never know but you know I didn't want to
like hide anything from her um she it
did not hurt her feelings I guarantee it
um and and she still loves me and I she
probably won't get me a paperweight
again but the thing is if I wasn't
honest with her you know what she might
do is believe
you probably got multiple stacks of
paper after I've got this other paper
where you're going to love so I kind of
nip at the bud right away um but at the
end of the day if I took that from her
so she gave me a gift to be happy she
wanted me to be happy when I get the one
home with that and I held on to it out
of sentimental reason if I held on to it
because I thought that that's what she
wanted me to do but at the end of the
day it made me unhappy to hold on to
that it's kind of doing it this service
to my grandma I mean at the end of the
day like she gave that to me to be happy
and if it's making me unhappy like if I
gave you a paperweight and you relay
unhappy with it I feel like a picture I
would just be like oh well just give her
to go donate it or get with it or
something and I don't want you to be
unhappy and I know that's how my grandma
feels too so anyone that gives you a
gift and the gift is causing stress in
your life I promise you that that person
does not want to cause you stress so at
that point it's okay to find that thing
a new home even if someone gifted it to
you because at the end of the day they
want you to be happy that's what it gave
you the gift and not having the gift
makes you happy I assure you they don't
want you to hold on to it um the other
thing too
thank you that's what it was
I just need 20 more to win this no I
think at the end of the day anyone who
is offended by you getting rid of
something that you gave them that's on
them and that's a protect them
projecting this insecurity of oh my god
I didn't know what to get this person
and you know what they didn't and that's
okay it doesn't make them a bad person
that also doesn't mean that they have to
you know be mean to you because because
you got rid of this thing I guess my
short answer would be as an adult you
get to choose what to do with your
things
[Applause]
[Music]
then if I could give it another short
answer here don't be burdened by other
people's burdens all right so well let's
let's move on hold the text your
question about a free welcome thank you
guys so what are we hugging or what well
yeah we all hugged right now get one
bring in place Oh sing some a whole lot
of love well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the pubs are free and transferable
afterward but we're not done yet we're
still we're still recording basic
appreciate a brother so we should
probably move on to our added value
segment so we usually talk about like
things that have added value to our
lives recently and this is the point
where I recommend the most recent Drake
album or something but I heard oh my go
hey we love Drizzy I'm just saying but
since we are we're in a different city
we get to only roll in here for dare to
go to most place so we try to find great
coffee great food museums etc and then
we have a chance to talk about so Ryan
what has been adding value to your lives
today or while we've been in Grand
Rapids oh man um fish lad where I got to
lobster roll
god I had no idea to get him lobster
roll in Michigan and it was freaking
good
we were right by the water uh-huh also I
went to uh oh no mad cap yeah whiz it
mad capper cap cap that's what I said
Kevin I know
no mad Cabot you ever been there whoo
good copy and it's in the Midwest band
life yeah well I mean there's often
coffees manoa so give her home but like
Grand Rapids we were here at 2014 and it
was a great city don't get me wrong we
just didn't mix to madcap that domino
effect no but three years later dude
this city has like totally raised its
game like yeah so yeah Matt cast pitch
lads both of which are it's of downtown
market yeah that place is great really
cool place but 2x
places if you are a coffee lover like
Josh and I are we are connoisseurs
speaking of coffee I we just bit of
coffee tour today my partner in Rebecca
is with me tea somewhere in the audience
and she was hiding out somewhere she
shot that she probably won't say hi but
hello Rebecca and ingest was with the
spoon we took the bus over to the west
side which by the way you learn a lot
about a city when you yeah one side and
you don't a lot about a city when you
take a bunch the first thing I recommend
if you live here locally and you haven't
been on the bus in a while like I know
that most people who live in a place
don't take a bus if they have a car
do it it's it's okay and you learn a lot
about about a city you get to interact
with people and you get to go places you
may not go and so we head over the west
side we went over to parents coffee with
the grade and then I got more coffee at
Roasters you have avenues shop on the
left side now I've been to the one over
here so anyway I went there and I got
some awesome sushi ATL is that place
yeah there's one person like I like
sushi yeah so I guess those would be my
recommendations check them out
especially if you're if you're listening
to this at home and you're coming
through Grand Rapids there are three
great coffee recommendations for you and
some really great food
Oh in real food cafe holy moly I think I
had the best omelet of my life this
morning it was so good anyway we should
probably move on to two right here right
now so we talked about going on in life
to the minimalist so before we get that
to that
well afterward about 20 minutes after
the events over Ryan and I will be out
front we'll be fishing out hub for
signing books taking photos and and all
of that fun stuff any of you could
photos night you want to share it online
you can just use the hashtag les is now
that's the name of the tour and we will
reshare some of our favorites or at
least Jeff's well she'll find some good
ones and post those speaking of it or if
you listen to this at home we're in the
middle of a 40 city tour right now we're
coming to a city really close to you
and if you'd like to see us you can
we're going to talk about minimalism we
will record a live version of the
podcast like we're doing right now you
find all the cities and dates over at
les is now calm and also we refuse to
clutter our podcast with advertisements
and so if you do want to help us we have
we did set up a patreon account if you
want to help support us we like a dollar
or two an episode none of the money goes
to me or Ryan by the way if we're
building a new podcast studio in a film
studio so we can create some meaningful
video creations and also we could so we
could pay Sean Bobcat Shawn a full-time
living wage for his whole family yeah
thank you and even if there's any money
left over from all that none of that
goes to me Ryan either will donate any
of the additional proceeds to charity so
if you if you want to help us out if you
want to help us create something
meaningful we're not going to put
advertisements on there but we could
really use your help with that you just
go to the minimal comm and you can click
on the little donate icon at the top you
can find our patreon on the page right
there I know you pay to get in here and
we should appreciate that because it
allows us to pay this fast
the video and everyone else and Ryan and
I don't make any money from touring but
you spent more than your money to
computer night you gave up your two most
precious resources for a few hours your
time and your attention and we're
grateful for that and I don't know where
you're going from here but if you leave
here with just one message after all of
this and hopefully we'll see some of you
at least out in the lobby after this
will take about a 20 minute twenty five
minute break or so and then we'll be out
there but if you leave here with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for being here yo
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi my name is Dan and I wanted to offer
something for Margaux from episode 89
who was talking about managing fear
while going through changing in terms of
giving up belonging she had attachments
too and it reminded me of a quote from
Trina Paulus and the quote goes how does
one become a butterfly she asked you
must want to fly so much that you are
willing to give up being a caterpillar
and it reminds me that in order to fully
grasp something do you're going to have
to let go on something else hi my name
is Kristen I'm from Charlotte North
Carolina I wanted to comment on the
previous podcast in terms of not
necessarily having to make a massive
salary in order to save it's not always
what you have coming in financially but
how much you have flowing out someone
can make half a million a year and spend
a million or you can make twenty five
thousand a year and spend fifteen
thousand and look at that you're
actually able to save a lot more living
paycheck to paycheck is not just a
function of having a particular type of
job and I find it's important not to let
yourself be caught up in that what do
you do socio-economic comparison and
keeping up with the Joneses that's been
become such a norm and remembering that
everyone is living out their own
experience and so many people wear that
mask and keep up this shiny facade and
the trail of perfect life Facebook posts
but keeping in mind you mainly just see
what others want you to see and it's not
productive to fall into that trap of wow
there life must be so great I want what
they have but knowing you know the grass
isn't always greener and happiness is
something you make inside of yourself
and not just wishing what others have
but being grateful for what you have and
there's a really beautiful quote I tell
my yoga classes it's not who you are
that's the problem it's who you think
you're not so be you love who you are
start where you're at and do the best
you can
hey Josh and Ryan this is Andy from
Portland Oregon I wanted to call to give
you guys a packing tip so I have done a
lot of traveling in my life ace to
travel for work four to five days a week
and since then now I just travel for fun
usually but one of the best things that
I
came across to really minimize what I
travel with is to pack an advance to try
to pack for my trip a couple days and
really lay out my outfits for each day
see what items I can mix and match then
I put it all in the suitcase and I wait
and then two days before the trip I'll
go in and say what can I remove what do
I not think that I'll need I find that
when I revisit my outfits or my planning
that it's easier for me to take out a
couple excess items I like to consider
myself somewhat fashionable so whether
it's a bag or a pair of shoes or shirt I
usually find that I can take out one or
two items
this is allowed me to go to China and
Russia for three weeks both for fun and
for work all in a carry-on hey everybody
it's Joshua fields Millburn and I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist I was just looking up the
dates for the second leg of the lessons
now torso so Ryan and I we are in the
middle of this crazy 40 city tour we're
doing a live talk about minimalism in
depth talk about minimalism we're also
recording a live version of the
minimalist podcast we're answering a
bunch of your questions
in person and oh yeah and we dish out a
bunch of free hugs after we're optional
hugs yes yeah we do hand hugs too if
they have if that's your thing whatever
you like we were looking forward to
seeing you on the road you can head on
over to les is now calm but here's the
cities that we're coming to for the
second leg of this 40 City tour we're in
V in Canada again oh man I can't wait I
love Canada we're going to be at Toronto
Ottawa Montreal Vancouver Calgary
Edmonton where they were headed to the
east coast of the United States we're
going to be in Philadelphia we'll be in
Manhattan and Brooklyn two stops in New
York Leno you've made it well we've
never had a stop in Brooklyn so that's
pretty cool yeah I mean we'll be in Salt
Lake City Denver and Phoenix heading
over to the mountains and then we're
touring internationally we'll be in
Texas
where we're going to be in Austin and
Dallas and Houston and then nashville
washington DC atlanta and tampa we're
finishing off with the cell almost but
then there's no better place to spend
december than in detroit and Milwaukee
wait who told you that our booking agent
Oh perfect yeah so we're going to be a
Detroit in Milwaukee that's we're going
to finish the lessons now tour this year
Helen over to Les is now calm you can
get your tickets you can find the dates
the theaters and you can see us soon
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little singing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it every little thing
that you got ahead every little singing
that you guys you gotta reach for you
got a grin
oh I bet that you'll be fine without so
tear your eyes
[Music]